[Music]
welcome podcast alright and we are live
along podcast Lords a gaming dotnet with
Laura PD and Lord snailed oh here we
check it out wasteland 3 man this is
definitely coming to the Xbox one of the
highly anticipated titles and we all get
right into him he'll get right into this
gameplay so our right mouse button is
going to give us the gasps the Kodiak
armored assault vehicle this is like a
nice now for the purpose of this demo
here we're actually going to be on a
linear path directly to Aspen it's
deceptively more complex with this demo
let's say you go a whole bunch places
but they try and keep you on path
still PD when you get to Aspen here
that's where they actually couldn't
begin in this demo being look at that
snow look at that it's really the
animation get the steam go this has come
a long way ways that I wanted I played
it is definitely a long way looking
really nice how's that control fellow I
look I like it it's pretty good I love
how the steams coming up behind it it's
like melting as we're going there we
enhancements baby it's cold out here we
got we got our big truck we move it
we're moving right now just pushing
through here that's of narrows narrative
for Norway for a Leawood
so probably it seems being held it looks
like we gotta go save those sale if I
got ejective all right Aspen snow was
okay sorry follow home families let's go
in
let's go roll in now once you get in
here one of the things I might suggest
doing is hit and see to take a look at
the pre loads for these particular
characters we're starting you off a
little bit more advanced in the game
than where you're gonna be at me
play the retail version of the game here
so let's take a look at our characters
and see who might be good for what
we're back we went back to the beginning
so I think just took anywhere okay we're
right in all right so hit that humans
worry on the left hand side they're up
top mm-hmm all right so from left to
right you've got a fellow here he's a
trooper click the next one here see we
got
alright looks like our UIs have a little
bit of a hiccup here but anyway our
first guy is gonna be our trooper he's
got an m16 our second fellow is a heavy
assault gunner he's got a like an m16
laying down suppressive fire this guy
looks like snake eyes this is Daraa as
GI Joe right there that's classic you
guys know baby this is our sniper and
then we have our Scotch bomb and he's
outfitted with a nice little shotgun
here so close that out
one of my tank bottom right okay so
rather than take the whole group in I
might suggest taking our surveillance
trooper or sniper break him out and
let's take him wandering a little bit up
front here because spoiler we got a
whole bunch of baddies
we have an area vision you're gonna see
as you get closer
so rather than knock on the door and let
him there know you're there bring your
sniper in maybe position him up on that
nice little elevated stack up there for
the levels back to the left to the left
yeah so even if the area of site
overlaps that and he's up there they're
not going to see him your vision is
gonna carry up there so it's just
similar to like a mutant here God being
here zero is like you can move around
until you get into combat
okay yeah let's go yeah
[Music]
yeah you see that cold that's like the
Metal Gear Solid Crew
that's actually a very popular thing
we're seeing a lot of people are
befriending the Fox this becomes a
different game which in chat with a box
so you do have actions down at the
bottom over where your action points
would be you see what you have your
utility belt okay the left of that gun
bench oh not right there see it there
you have team animal right oh wow
animal tape okay okay
looks like a friend you made a very
committed softly looked up at you I will
describe the thoughts behind the bits of
my brain oh / there's a lot of love
going on right now oh oh we were teaming
foxes
Caliban has started we have been
detected Oh
[Music]
it's old not enough action points
oh so now we have to go into combat yeah
we're in like the combat base oh yeah so
as you are strategize I'm gonna do an
work here keep in mind also that the
Kodiak combat vehicle it's also clip and
we looking at noon for a there also a so
and now but let's just go get them yeah
they're just go get'em it there's no
more you know the covert mission you can
literally have two people at once and
hotel for
you don't want to run over your guys
though oh yeah it's cool just move our
guys out the way let's get that going
that will end the quarter because we
gotta go get up with the truck though
this is awesome to an area with that
highlighted blue that means you're still
having a factual points to this one shot
you're moving the yellow there it means
that move that location but you will not
be able to execute a shot so what does
that leadership mean yeah but now the
leadership chance increase yeah you got
to stand next to you later you give you
confidence man it's what he does so
ambush is kind of ambition to be willing
to spend extra ammo and action points
about defending location so we can move
forward sir oh oh oh that's a big boy
it's a big one
shoot these guys here hey let's get it
just shoot this specific target if
they're Splash Damage yeah and let's get
him okay yeah machine gun to lay him out
lay the power so what I'm talking about
I said this guy
it feels like an episode of GI Joe
turn-based already oh oh it's multiple
shots keep in mind on your left hand
side there with your ring finger and
your index finger with Q and E you did a
little pan the camera you can also zoom
in okay so if you wanted to try and see
maybe the perspective of the enemies of
what they're thinking is you're trying
to figure out your own strategy
go ahead play with that camera nice nice
[Music]
so they show you your damages okay so
you're got enough action points to move
outside that radius I will be like to
rise and run over here you sure you got
enough that's like nine action points
for that
alright the middle of nowhere we can do
it you can do it did Oh
Oh not a bad choice right a bad choice
oh I don't wanna make sure he was able
to do it
remember this guy you were trying to be
friendly to the Fox that's all that
matters how was the end game please we
have an animal friendship animals all
right so let's finish let's finish these
boys off so there's nothing left to do
for them yes honey Oh ginger
Oh executed ambushed you saw a shot take
did taking it's almost I almost felt
like an overwatch kind of did yeah
that's that's what I thought yeah I fell
over watching for this guy
so the courier are you able to match
them to my treatment in the ring with it
that way okay now is there someone that
can heal the reason when Saturn yeah so
I know at least scotch Moe has the
ability to heal right now and he has a
specific med kit I believe he can use
known other people so Scott's mo is
close to say banshee go to your
inventory first so the seventh circle
press c OC hmm yeah go into inventory
and our UI is going to be a little wonky
here so I don't know if it's going to
let you do it but what you would
typically do is you would take that med
kit box go up on top row the medic pack
even drop that into there's a slot
though it would be down here for you I
it's not if you want to restart you're
welcome to do that that's why this
particular stations been a little lumpy
here it's all good so good we're sharing
early early early bill
let's go now we're really gonna use that
cover with it with it with the guest
yeah let's do it
I was worried about him retaliating with
you with that but I'm glad you got him
out of there oh yeah that's got about
you got a shotgun you used a shotgun I
respect that
let's get that tank in the mat next oh
my god hey you got a big tank meat even
you'll say just real real pacifist with
it oh I don't want to like run the guy
over you know smart
I'll respect average my respect that you
like GT because enough that you want to
run him over
I would away in am over just to go so I
just want to you to take so bad I'm all
about that tape so once a particular
character has successful enough they're
gonna have their precision strike which
is that glowing button this allows you
to dial in the shot for a more specific
kind of effect on the enemy you need so
you can select that and then you attack
going to move off you got to be the
range
that's a tiny little village it's a big
quality parts nice so you could be very
boring specific dice it's very hard I'm
feeling this
everybody's got the nice lower
attributes a lot of lot of synergies I
want you use that move yeah what in
lights nobody I know I want to see that
next term sure
I think I'll finish this too before do
you guys this specific demo is more
combat focused right just for the
purposes of making sure people kind of
take in feel it out in the amount of
time they're a lot here at the
convention button the hallmark Oh bull
market up the wasteland series is the
deep robust RPG choices and character
creation through yeah it's just gonna
taste here for combat through some RPG
elements in this demo experience the end
awesome yeah that was some of the things
I've known it's like I'm new to the
franchise and um playing waste and when
I noticed actually about every choice
matter everything everything it and the
fact that that still exists in the
franchise and I know we're focusing just
on a combat for combat area but that's
that's really cool that that's still
going on firing through in the dream
just rip them up finish them up not a
rough range upon how you roll with the
options with that fellow can change a
thousand different voice options later
on down the road Wow and that's just one
of several different important choices
they're all important but significant
choices that come to bear as you go
through the play awesome awesome
loving it man this is this is this is a
gay what copper be like I feeling this
I want to know how we get this take the
rolled up we go now he's taking a little
bit of damage I think this is undercover
yeah you doing the moonwalk so it's a
little interesting I think he's
practicing with the batteries at his
booth for the beta for the same okay
right yeah your chance to succeed with
the rain shot like that is 50 minutes if
they are behind cover right and for that
we're still limited as far as movement
with the tank as far as we can't go
through certain barriers stuff like that
right okay so we stand with us about
sports we're gonna begin up yeah it's at
this point now we got to get the troops
out and start finishing things or okay
it was like the ultimate support
character in a way exactly
now the Kodiak has customizable its
weaponry cosmetics be able take it back
to the garage
Oh apparently when you're using a rocket
launcher you can't be around anybody
yeah because I see like there's a
friendly quiet or is that because
exactly
sort of
like a sickle definitely looks like it
yeah
let's do it let's see what happens
Wow okay yes that's that's one of the
map is making a mega ball dance it's all
good we are the early bells what this
game is more walkable again so all these
guys are lootable - yeah nice so you're
gonna pick up naturally Luke that's next
to the character see you you're not
going to go through the Madonna that's
awesome that's awesome
lower the drawbridge you can access that
generator that's back there did that
pole activate that generating range yeah
over the Gopher so we got different
skill sets and stuff like that for the
characters pretty cool for mechanics
more actions maybe another unit I don't
know so we gotta figure we gotta figure
out this is we added a question learners
so we gotta figure it out all right I
heard daddy told you to call me old vic
buchanan gosh damn great to meet you
were rolling out the red carpet oh it's
on now that's big big big big at all or
some
or a clue about this inaudible rush at
all but just to kind of inform you for
this demo if you were to hang a left
after the drawbridge you bring yourself
much quicker to the last encounter if
you want to take your time no no let's
get there let's get there no no right
there let's go right there
biggest talker
yeah see bodies hanging
oh man I forgot the blocks yeah press
the spacebar should make sure you are
gonna head in its lucky ball there you
go
oh it's always sucks yeah oh nice there
are times where it's advantageous to
have the whole groups lifted nice if you
don't know what's around the corner
obviously happens one surveillance agent
going through it's never a bad idea
new construction I'll just assume
they're like yes go for it I suppose no
no no they're not honest Bob is welcome
oh yeah this what I want to see take the
heat take the oh they got bodies out
it's real in this section this section
of the wasteland is real mistakes were
made mistakes were made we're taking the
heat literally
taking the heat going the wrong way
I see stance in the flames
[Music]
yeah we are
oh then it automatically will but the
most important thing is the box is still
alive yes yes that's what's most
important
that is the endgame keeping the fox
alive
[Music]
are we under this one
because of
yeah man so we see if we can get to the
spinning part right see if we get to
that I'll be crazy
no it's like wow puzzle this is great so
is it an issue with the movement has
moving him as a single unit versus the
group is that was given a little bit of
putting him like as far as like I know I
just have a little issue gets do that
part with the dig so they were like
moving on a group it looks like the way
that the AI was programmed no they were
taking like a longer route as a volka
yeah like
I feel like this would turn this off
right yeah you're that off too
old lady one stop away they've all he
won't stack ceiling oh well it like you
died
does he good no no
the bed kids oh it was a weird animation
for the Olympic after that I thought he
was I saw blood
that's gonna be necessary yes much
couldcould become especially during this
section
yes
[Music]
so take the worked make the cut I love
it
this guy's like very sadistic there's
big guys really so yeah make the cut
for the heat
yeah this is a hundred years after the
bombs fell desert Rangers which are now
in Colorado we're trying to do best they
can to be successful in procuring more
supplies and we can bring back home it's
done ASCO there's a deactivate whatever
commit but dudes do well evacuate your
deactivation skill was a different
everybody is running straight head on
into yeah we have it we have a
deactivation issues so this this
specific little puzzle here has a trick
to it
it's the were in which okay gotcha so
you always get a sequence yeah we always
do have one played active
went off now so we gotta hit all the
buttons and then see okay I see what's
going on god she got she's right hitting
that third one again it doesn't kill you
it's your third one yeah
[Applause]
yeah yeah try that one
hmm
I'm at the for right before are you
[Music]
all right Aaron a stereo whoo we don't
lost all the squab but we got the puzzle
done someone managed their home revived
yes please
gouge aye
walk still kicking yeah barely run with
the big all here we go run with the big
dogs
let's not let's not let's not let's not
let's not do that
again you can change the camera if you
want to you don't have to told plan yeah
I would change the camera just so we
could see it you say you can change the
camera in the game I guess don't have to
though I mean don't leave the camera one
position this one I get different
weaponry
at school
where do we have to go to the birds
stairs up the steps well maybe not sorry
guess you're gonna flip beers you know
it's wrong other friendly year right I
don't know find out yeah right call
you'd be in the real koi
oh she got a fox - Fox speaks better
send a fox in it
Oh oh it's real
Aaron why are you
Oh Carl Bette has started its combat
history
I just why these guys run all the way
down here we got to work on our movement
skill as a group
eggs diapers don't do so hot in close
range yeah
it's getting real we got to get the
cavalry and then top out the boys
oh yes you can receive
Oh
come on scotch moe
come on Scotch ball did shoot Scotch
Bowl we need you doc nails in
Scottsville we got to get growler
growler one wow that wasn't encouraging
see some strong bears
yeah the corn will hit double Jo yeah so
I hate going okay okay all right all
right making progress
and there's a growler car what do you
use I want to use this what you want to
use as Sam you want to rocket launch it
a bit I want to see what it looks like
Savage
No leave a couple owned a company had
nothing to do with it
take my bear
oh he already okay punch each other
let's go oh trap shenanigans
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
always poisonous is not good
elbows down buchanan is in the doors I
would say the earth one o'clock position
bring your out right now okay so it's
the big garage doors there behind the
big bad guys sitting there let's do it
so I'm sorry you're saying we're saying
it the main bad guy of this will demo
big Buchanan who shouldn't say bad guy
because it's all relative to how you
forget he's underneath that marquee like
there's a garage door right there you
can see when you highlight it yeah yeah
through that section is where you find
them I still get it just kind of giving
you up Freyja the reference because by
going through this path you've actually
got a short circuit in the main way you
walk out let's go again let's go down
by using a spacebar to move all together
or
this is gonna happen is we're gonna like
regular combat yeah reflect perfect less
yeah yeah better like super damaged
also you have to target somebody you
know I got talking someone individually
invalid
there you go
invalid which is a Serb invalid tools
so at this
you get that precision shot of a nice
yes look at that a low ability
paroled multi-kill nice
out of range
as the red lines will tell you who to
target you
okay
what you'd feel that guy and miss
the messiness got arranged all right
classic
we're gonna keep pushing
now remember we got to get to after we
kill it we gotta get to that green door
remember
nice
[Music]
there we go
hey that was unexpected dad was not
expected
I like this ability though every school
that's pretty cool yeah did you get like
a target thing almost comes like a
little close up that egg all right but
the chance though what's the percentage
I know
we gotta get scotch bo that's my man
nice noise let's go
storm the gate
my mascot Josh boy ain't got no hey
Lenny no we got to do we got to do about
that's that gate we got to go let's go
let's go get Vic I'll show you guys
stuff oh my god and turn can you hit him
with that liability and I am oh wow
why
in turn yeah Paul you may order you man
it's got some over-design nice
he said you killed my Brennus oh well
step it to the gun Dola
remember settled ahead that on that big
that door yeah everybody's hurt but you
know
[Music]
oh boy
nice to grow this race smokes about
that's deputation to the drama
yes our boy
mmm final frontier final confrontation
full full voice full voice it's nice
all the other choices I think we're at
that I think we're choice to around good
okay cool oh yes
kiss-ass requirement not met we got
you're not funny I remember in the first
place there was that like you develop
skills become a kiss-ass whatever
depending on the type of home questions
you ask I remember that for the further
so which I'm a home
Jack let's go
yeah oh
you disobeyed a pig that killed his son
Wow just be thinking about but there's
not gonna make daddy baby understand
when you tell them I'm not Wow there you
have it wasteland 3 you're a little
podcaster prove coming to Xbox and PC
very expensive on on the last one any
final thoughts sir great game a lot of
fun I had a lot of great vibes flying it
let's get out just learn how to control
you people but all yeah I did make sure
we put them in the right spot make sure
they don't get anywhere you know poisons
or grenades it go down waste layer three
of
you
[Music]